but the most important thing i can say
is thank you so much
and that i'm okay
i am so indebted to you and by the way
i'm okay with a piece of [ __ ]
so my question of the day first is at
what point did you personally realize
that jesse smullet was completely full
of crap that's
my question to you uh for people who
don't remember
i think we have a we have a clip right
this is something it was inspired by c
when i was watching cnn yesterday
this this girl from vox talked about the
importance
of media outlets who didn't cover this
story and didn't call it a hague let's
just watch the clip yeah
i mean the the maga quote i remember
reading about the story and looking
for a real uh reputable media outlet
reporting on that and i could not find
one
right how about yours repeating that
quote were not news
outlets were not media outlets it was
repeated by
short people who maybe had good
intentions of wanting to spread the
story and had empathy for what they
thought was you know a real story
but we can't confuse celebrity tweets
with the media and the press
we can't confuse it with say every major
media outlet
there yeah there you go that's just a
few new york post
uh what do we have there we have advice
tmz tmz
you know yeah you've made it pretty easy
for us to confuse journalism with other
things though right it's kind of y'all's
fault
it's been hard to follow but this is one
thing i just
when i look back on the comments made by
jesse here when he knew by the way we
don't know entirely for sure this
segment may not age well
um or it may be the tip of the iceberg i
mean let's be
these honest knowingly lying there's no
other way to say it
that that's why it brings us to uh the
newest installment new segment i guess
that we call
what a piece of [ __ ]
that was fast all right here we go so
let's go through this here
so he reported the attack on january
29th
uh along with what's so funny is you
report these details of
the the rope at two in the morning
homophobic slurs
country uh if they poured bleach on him
like
very detailed reporting this is chicago
officers
i mean looking back when when you first
heard this again we all thought well
maybe hold on not all of this is
accurate maybe the media isn't being
entirely transparent
no he's making it all up what a piece of
[ __ ]
what an absolute i love going back here
and looking at some of his quotes okay
here look let me look at some of these
quotes right here this is
uh uh all right hold on okay wait
wait for it this is great this is where
you said on february 1st it is first
public statement again just looking back
or traveling a time machine
let me start by saying that i'm okay
thank god my body is strong
but my soul is stronger
is he auditioning for his next job
somewhere potentially
the outpouring of love and support from
my village
has meant more than i will ever be able
to truly
words what a piece of [ __ ]
there's no other way to put this oh my
gosh
hold on then he goes on what's so funny
is he he went out at this point keep in
mind at this point
what everyone is criticizing him he
knows full well that he's lying
i don't know why there's just something
so funny to me picturing him laying just
awake in bed at night going oh crap
he said he said this when he was met
with skepticism i am working with
authorities
and have been 100 factual and consistent
on every level
[Laughter]
despite my frustrations and deep concern
with certain inaccuracies
and misrepresentations that have been
spread i still believe that justice will
be served
he's right what a piece of [ __ ]
it will be served he was performing at a
uh a concert in west hollywood
i'm not entirely sure if it was a
benefit uh but he says
i have so many words on my heart that i
want to say
but the most important thing i can say
is thank you so much
and that i'm okay
he's going after this point just so talk
about
this sort of culture of victimhood going
on what's the most important thing i can
say is
thank you please it's not it's not me
it's you
thank you i am i am so indebted to you
and by the way i'm okay
what a piece of [ __ ] this excited time
he knows oh my gosh and this is
something else
too he goes and he says uh uh this is
february 14th
this is after by the way there are two
guys you know it seems likely
the story is not entirely confirmed that
two black guys one of whom was an extra
empire very big dudes were paid to do
this
and that his personal trainer purchased
the rope
elaborately cliche he left his interview
good morning america my favorite quote
from there is where it says
it feels like this is after people are
questioning him it feels like if i had
said it was a muslim or a mexican
or someone black i feel like the
doubters would have supported me much
what a piece of human [ __ ]
[Laughter]
how do you i bet he was going to bed
every night please dear god don't let
them investigate thoroughly
because this is going to ask questions
please don't ask questions
for me when that was released i'm like
okay we're getting somewhere i don't
have any doubt in my mind that that's
them
i never did piece of [ __ ]
everything this guy has said has been so
dis and of course it's obviously the
real problem here is that the media has
allowed him to get away with it oh of
course they were ready with open arms to
believe any story that was remotely like
this
by the way hit the hit the notification
bell if you're a subscriber because
apparently it doesn't mean anything on
itunes enjoy
mug club and i'm sorry this is
incredibly immature
it's very fitting come on but some
there's someone worse than jesse
smallitt out there
there is smallett smallett
but it doesn't matter because this is so
this is this is i think
uh perfectly emblematic of the media
coverage and the reaction that we saw
and then by the way they say well we
need to do we need to distinguish
between
celebrities and news media outlets first
off all of you covered it
second you all praise the celebrities as
bray brave who covered this issue
case in point ellen page on a late night
comedy show
stephen colbert what happened the other
day did you say i don't know him
personally i saw
i sent all of my love instead it's like
we have a media that's barely talking
about it
we have a media that's saying it's a
debate whether or not which has happened
to jesse small it is a hate crime
it's absurd this isn't a debate
i agree
connect the doctor should be right about
everything she does this is the
and you want to cause suffering to them
you go through the trouble you spend
your career
trying to cause suffering what do you
think is gonna happen
kids are gonna be abused and they're
gonna kill themselves
and people are gonna be beaten on the
street
i have traveled the world and i have met
the most marginalized people you could
meet
i am lucky to have this time and the
privilege to say this
this needs to stop
this is this is what
this seems childish listen one uh
in one scenario that could be an earnest
display
for which we would all be incredibly
sensitive and
most definitely hell bound for laughing
and the other is entirely appropriate
the only difference even though this may
seem trivial is just like we always talk
about in this show
the only difference is truth and now
that we know the truth
that is absolutely hysterical i stand by
my statement
jesse small i really like this segment
what a piece of [ __ ] hey there if you
like this video this is the part where i
would usually tell you to subscribe but
i can't do it anymore i'm going to tell
you to subscribe and then youtube is
going to decide that
we can't reach you even though you
subscribe to this channel and then i'll
say hit the notification bell
and then the notification bell won't
even be there anymore
i don't know what to say more than
likely you'll find my face in a milk
carton but do what you can to stop it
it's just it's just it probably won't do
much